Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich erzähl euch jetzt mal was.
Ich kann heute nicht so wahnsinnig rumschreien.
Ich hab auch ein paar Bonbons am Start.
Ja, und abends muss ich ein bisschen husten.
Ich hoffe halt, wie gesagt, ich hoffe, dass es eine normale Erkältung ist.
Und nicht Corona.
Aber, also ich erzähl euch mal was.
Und zwar, ich war
Dienstag
beim Superspreader-Event
schlechthin in Frankfurt.
Legacy of the Beast.
50.000 Leute.
In der Commerzbank-Arena.
Ne, nicht Commerzbank-Arena.
Heißt nicht mehr so.
Deutsche Bank Park.
Heißt es jetzt ja.
Und
Mittwoch ging
ja, 5000 Leute waren es.
Ungefähr.
Ich glaube, es passen maximal
66.000 oder so rein.
Aber das hintere
Viertel hinter der Bühne
hat man natürlich nicht besetzt.
So.
Zumindest.
Mittwoch ging.
Also, vorgestern.
Vorgestern ging.
Und, ähm,
seit heute Nacht
musste ich husten.
Und mir hat auch der Hals weh getan.
Okay, vielleicht Klimaanlage, sonst wie.
Und es ist heute
schlechter geworden.
Tag über.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar Bonbons lutschen.
Und ich fühl mich auch irgendwie
warm an.
Ich hab noch kein Fieber gemessen.
Und ich will mir jetzt auch nicht live im Stream,
auch wenn der Chat jetzt sagt,
ja, auf geht's, mach, mach ich nicht.
Ich will mir jetzt auch nicht live im Stream
das Thermometer in Pobo schieben.
Live, live Fieber mäßig.
Das machen wir nicht.
Das war ein Test.
Test hab ich auch noch nicht gemacht.
Und ich sag euch auch, warum ich noch keinen Test gemacht hab.
Nicht unter den Achseln.
Thermometer kommt in Pobo.
Dann funktioniert das.
Stimmt das wenigstens auch, was draufsteht.
Wird richtig Gachi Bass reingerollt.
Bis zum Anschlag.
Nee, ich geht, Alter.
Das tut ja weh.
Nein.
Aber nicht unter die Achseln.
Ja, Thermometer muss schon in Pobo.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Das muss in den Hintern.
Ich mein, vielleicht geht das ja,
vielleicht würde dieser Content auch
unter Pools durchgehen.
Ich mach ein bisschen Wasser im Hintergrund.
Dann ist gut.
Also.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also, ich hab noch keinen Test gemacht, weil
ich habe im Internet geguckt
und die sagen, eigentlich
wenn du willst,
dass dieser Test halbwegs
aussagekräftig ist,
dann musst du vier bis fünf Tage warten.
Und meistens
dauert es auch,
bis man von Corona
richtig viel merkt, dass der Test in Pobo ist.
Und man merkt auch vier bis fünf Tage.
Oder fünf bis sechs sogar eher.
Aber als Zement-Effekt,
es spricht eher
nicht für Corona,
dass ich jetzt schon was im Hals merke,
aber,
dass ich husten muss,
ist natürlich schon mal schlecht.
Zumal ich halt,
wie gesagt,
auf dem Event schlechthin war,
um mir Corona einzufangen.
Wenn man sich irgendwie,
ja, war bei dir auch so,
na toll,
ist doch wie bei mir.
Dann ist doch ähnlich wie bei mir.
Dienstag eingefangen,
ab heute Nacht,
beziehungsweise heute Tag, so über Hals
und Husten
und, äh,
tja, mal schauen.
So, ne,
vor fünf bis sechs Tagen nicht,
daheim kriegst du kein Corona.
Zumindest, also, du hast sogar
das leichte Rauschen, pock.
Kollege hat sich auf dem Iron Maiden-Konzert
angesteckt. Ach, da, wo ich auch war?
Na toll.
Ich sag doch,
Superspreader-Event.
Also,
wie gesagt, ich, das fühlt sich auch ein bisschen warm an,
wenn ich mich angreife, so hier
Gesicht und, äh,
so auch an der Seite und so.
Äh, muss ich mal gucken.
Also, ich werd nach dem Stream mal ne Runde
Thermometer in Poppes schieben.
Ja, wenn's nur das wäre, wär ja okay.
Da hatt ich ja keine Schmerzen mit.
Aber ich fürchte
fast, ich mein, ich hab's bis jetzt
man's not hot
genau.
Ähm, aber
ich, ups, falsches, falsches Emote.
Aber ich,
aber ich
hat's bis jetzt umschifft mit
Corona, also ich habe
die dumme Vermutung,
dass mich's jetzt erwischt hat.
Das wäre ziemlich kacke.
Aber
früher oder später
kommst du da wahrscheinlich nicht drum herum.
Mal gucken, wie's morgen ist.
Gucken, wie's morgen ist.
Ich trink viel Zeug. Ach ja,
und das Beste ist, hab ich euch ja gar nicht erzählt,
warum das, warum das nochmal extra kacke ist.
Mir geht's dann nämlich ohne Corona
schon nicht so gut, weil ich hab euch ja schon
vor ein paar Wochen erzählt, dass ich Zahnweh hatte.
Und ich war ja ein paar Mal beim Zahnarzt,
der wusste nicht so wirklich, was Sache ist.
Man sieht irgendwie nix, hat Röntgenbild gemacht und alles.
Und der hat jetzt ein paar Sachen
probiert. Und dann hatte ich
letzte Woche Freitag
einmal Wurzelbehandlung.
Und
jetzt tut mir der Zahnweh beim draufbeißen
und drum herum alles.
Also ich hab quasi
bald Zahnschmerzen
und Corona.
Obwohl man eigentlich, also ich hoffe das nicht,
dass es Corona ist, aber ja.
Obwohl man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen müsste,
dass nach der Wurzelbehandlung man nichts mehr spürt.
Und ja, am Zahn spür ich
auch nix mehr. Also weder noch heiß
noch kalt.
Aber drum herum. Und es wird eher schlechter
als besser. Ich hoffe es legt sich
dieses Wochenende wieder.
Ja und sollte ich jetzt irgendwie
Erkältung oder Corona haben, kann ich auch nicht
zum Zahnarzt gehen.
Also muss ich ein paar Pillen einschmeißen.
Ich mein aktuell geht's. Aber gerade ist wirklich
gerade ist wirklich alles
Zusammenkacke, ja.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht,
ich mach jetzt mal streamen.
So, ich hab Salbei-
Bonbons hier.
Ricola.
Salbei-Bonbons.
Muss ich ab und zu mal einfuttern.
Ne.
Der Zahn ist ja noch drin.
Das ist ja der Sinn von Wurzelbehandlung.
Naja, mal gucken.
Mal gucken wie das mit dem...
Wie war denn das bei dir?
Wir hatten das eben geschrieben.
Was war denn in deinem Hals?
Also wie war das bei dir mit Corona
und dem Hals? Der, der das eben
mit dem Hals geschrieben hat.
N3OG
Oder besser gesagt wahrscheinlich
Neo-G
Salbei. Salbei ist
Salbei ist an sich gut. Salbei ist gut,
wenn man Probleme mit dem Zahnfleisch hat.
Und gegen Hals.
Ach ja. Also.
Stimmt. Jetzt hab ich erstmal erzählt,
dass ich mir wahrscheinlich Corona eingefangen hab.
Beim Konzert.
Jetzt kann ich euch mal was erzählen, wie das Konzert war.
Also. Schauen wir doch mal.
Schauen wir doch mal kurz schnell.
Ob Leute Bilder
gepostet haben.
Ich hab ein paar Bilder gepostet.
Die sind jetzt aber nicht so wahnsinnig spannend.
Also das Konzert war tatsächlich
ziemlich nice.
Es waren drei Bands.
Also insgesamt war es halt wirklich
doch gar nicht schlecht, was man fürs...
Ne. Iron Maiden.
Oder es heißt eigentlich nicht Iron.
Es heißt Iron Maiden.
Weil irgendwie außer den Engländern
keiner checkt, dass man das R nicht ausspricht.
Und jeder sagt Iron.
Und ich auch. Aber ich weiß es eigentlich.
Bitte hör doch mal auf mich abzufacken hier.
Geh mal fort.
Muss ich wieder zu nitter.
Weil es sonst nicht funktioniert.
Gut.
Ja. Also.
Also bei mir ist es eher so.
Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, was man hat.
Normalerweise wenn man
Wenn man eine normale Erkältung kriegt.
Aber halt nicht so
Nicht so an einer Stelle.
Ja kratzen. Kratzen hab ich auch.
Es ist halt nicht an einer Stelle, sondern
komplett von links nach rechts durch den Hals.
Was bei normaler Erkältung
bei mir nicht so ist.
Na gut.
Zumindest. Also.
Mal gucken, ob Leute ein paar ordentliche Bilder gepostet haben.
Ah nitter. Kackt wieder ab. Na wunderbar.
Also. Man hat
Man hat tatsächlich relativ viel fürs Geld bekommen.
Also das Ticket hat glaub 95 Euro
oder so gekostet.
So plus minus. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
95 Euro.
Man konnte 5.45 Uhr rein.
Das ist aber total sinnlos.
15.45 Uhr ist viel zu früh.
Das ist für die ganzen Hardcore Fans,
die vorne in der ersten Reihe stehen wollen.
Das muss nicht sein.
Also konnte es 15.45 Uhr rein.
Wir waren irgendwie 16.30 Uhr oder so da.
Dann gab es erst Airborne
und dann gab es Powerwolf.
Powerwolf war richtig nice.
Ja und als es dann dunkel wurde,
hat Iron Maiden angefangen. Man muss halt sagen.
Schautechnisch war wirklich
extrem nice.
Ich meine man erkennt es ja ein bisschen.
Ich habe jetzt. Das ist nur ein iPhone Foto.
Das ist nicht die krasseste Auflösung oder so.
Aber ich glaube man erkennt es.
Also die haben was
Bühnentechnik
angeht schon da
alles an Register gezogen.
Also die hatten zig.
Das war nicht aufgeblasen. Das waren wirklich
irgendwelche gebauten
Dinger von Flugzeugen
bis hier so Köpfe
oder alles mögliche hatten die am Start auf der Bühne.
Von Feuerwerken
bis Feuer. Alles dabei.
Man muss sagen.
Für das das das richtig alte Säcke sind.
Ich meine Iron Maiden ist im Durchschnitt glaube ich
65 oder so.
Wenn einer zu mir nochmal Boomer sagt.
Da stehen die richtigen Boomer auf der
Bühne.
Der ist noch am Start. Der ist glaube ich der älteste.
Der ist glaube ich schon 70.
Im Durchschnitt sind die glaube ich 65, 66 oder so.
Also die sind richtig alt.
Man muss sagen. Also für einen
65 Jährigen hat der
schön Kilometer gemacht auf der Bühne.
Beim rumrennen.
So.
Zumindest die Soundqualität war halt
naja.
Ich habe gehofft hat noch irgendjemand anderes
ein paar Bilder gepostet.
Also die Soundqualität war richtig mies.
Nicht ganz so beschissen wie in der Festhalle
vor ein paar Jahren. Da waren die auch schon mal.
Aber
total übersteuert und hättest du
die Texte nicht gekannt.
Hättest du eigentlich nichts
mitbekommen.
Der Sound war wirklich
kacke.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nicht was die
in Frankfurt machen.
Aber ich würde eigentlich von ausgehen
dass das Konzert technisch in einem
Stadion doch mehr her machen
sollte.
Als so.
Naja.
Ansonsten war wirklich sehr nice.
Sound war naja. Also
die haben sich wirklich Mühe gegeben.
Die Show an sich war auch gut.
Preis-leistungsmäßig kannst du mit
drei Bands auch nicht meckern.
Powerwolf war richtig lang da.
Und die würde ich mir auch so angucken.
Also alleine im Konzert.
90 Euro, paar 90 Euro.
Das ging schon in Ordnung.
Ich mein du hattest
von 17 Uhr, 17 Uhr 45
bis
22 Uhr 45
da Entertainment.
Passt schon.
Ne ne.
Nix.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
Und wie gesagt wahrscheinlich
komm ich jetzt um Corona nicht rum.
Ich hoffe ja immer noch
dass es normale Erkältung und gut ist.
Das ist richtig. Ja.
Aber ansonsten.
Ich hab wie gesagt. Ich hoffe es ist ne normale Erkältung.
Aber ich fürchte
ich bin jetzt auch mal dran mit Corona.
Hast du das
schon mit Arjen Massner fehlerhaften GPG?
Ne hab ich nicht mitbekommen. Was war denn da?
Sag mal her.
Arj.
Ne das heißt nicht
pgp
heißt das.
Oder soll ich wirklich nach GPG suchen?
Ne.
Und was ist da?
Was ist da passiert?
Da ist der Fehler.
What the fuck?
Nö.
Lul.
Ähm.
Ich hab doch erst gestern
oder so Updates gemacht.
Ach Moment.
Ich hab ja Manjaro by the way.
Ich darf ja gar nicht Arj by the way by the way in by the way.
Weil es ist ja nur
Arj und kein
ist ja nur Manjaro und kein Arj.
Dann hab ich den Fehler wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich hab nen Arj
Linux hier installiert.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Ich hab ja heute sonst nichts großartiges geplant.
Also Leute. Der Titel ist Programm.
Wir schwätzen ein bisschen was. Gucken uns ein paar Videos an.
Ich glaub nicht, dass ich jetzt allzu lang das machen kann.
Wie gesagt, mir tut der Hals weh.
Und nachher nochmal Fieber messen.
Morgen mach ich. Also ich weiß nicht. Morgen ist ja Freitag.
Wahrscheinlich mach ich den Corona.
Ich hab nämlich nur noch zwei Corona Tests.
Hier.
Wahrscheinlich mach ich den Test
Samstag.
Dann ist lang genug Zeit
und dann sollte das anschlagen, wenn was ist.
Eigentlich hab ich ja gesagt, ich komme
morgen auf die Arbeit. Aber ich glaube,
das lass ich besser sein.
Natürlich. Als Homeoffice Fan
entgegenkommt.
Aber ich glaube in dem Fall sind
alle anderen auch der Meinung, es ist keine so gute Idee
mit Corona Symptomen
auf die Arbeit zu fahren.
Nö. Also wenn das so bleibt.
Tempel OS. Das hab ich schon auf. Das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Mit dem Hals und so.
Also solange es wirklich nur bei ein bisschen Husten
Hals und bisschen bisschen
Hot.
Man's not hot.
Bleibt. Tja. Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Wie die Sonnennacht ist. Ja. War gespannt.
So. Zeit. Lass mal kurz checken.
Was machen die Updates hier?
Pac-Man. Also bester Update
Befehl übrigens. Wer der Meinung
ist, dass sein System nicht updatet, dann sollst
mal damit probieren. Okay.
Manjaro updatet. Alles klar.
Dann machen wir mal Arch by the way an.
Und gucken, ob das updatet.
Jetzt werden wir jetzt ja gleich
sehen. Das werden wir jetzt
ja gleich sehen, ob das funktioniert.
Du du du.
Du du du du.
So.
Pac-Man. Alter, ich kann ja mal
tippen.
Äh.
Ne. Einfach nur so, ne?
Ja.
So.
Funktioniert doch alles.
Arch by the way. By the way funktioniert
by the way. Nicht?
Ah, das kommt, wenn
er die Keys überprüft. Danach erst.
Oder was? Der downloadet.
Okay. Sekunde. Das Downloaden dauert
mir ein bisschen zu langsam. Äh. Dauert mir ein bisschen
zu lang. Äh. Wo schaltet man,
wo schaltet man
parallele Downloads nochmal ein?
Das ist doch hier irgendwo.
Hier.
Bam. Jetzt. Alter, ich hoffe,
der Stream kackt nicht ab dabei.
Leute.
Schauen, schauen, ob's laggt.
Ah, ne.
Laggt nix. Du du du du.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Einfach mit Reflektor den
schnellsten Server suchen. Was ist denn Reflektor?
Jelly4, du hast bei der
Bahn Vorstellungsgespräche und musst mit der Bahn
fahren. Da stell ich mir, da
hab ich ne gute Ausrede. So. Und jetzt
Yes. Und jetzt kackt er
wahrscheinlich ab. Vermut ich mal.
Ah. Signature
von David Runge
ist Marginal Trust.
Oh oh.
Kackel.
Okay. Ich brech
mal ab. Ja. Na dann.
Arch by the way.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass so richtig richtig
Update kaputt ist, was ich mitbekommen hab.
Zeig doch mal kurz her,
was schreiben denn die
Arch by the way? Leute.
Außer, dass sie
Arch verwenden.
Es gibt ein Fix, werden wir jetzt gleich sehen.
Ich wollte das zwar...
Moment, Moment, Sekunde.
Zack, Zack. Dark Reader.
Wobei, hatte GitHub nicht selber
nen Dark Mode? Wo macht man den an?
Geht das auch ohne, dass man eingeloggt ist?
Leute, kann man einen Dark Mode
in GitHub anmachen, ohne dass man eingeloggt ist?
Ne, ne?
Ist das der richtige Dark Reader?
Ne. Dark Reader, Dark.
Dark Reader. Das ist das richtige.
Excellent.
Okay. Okay. Gut.
Also.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
This must be Arch's white problem or something.
Everyone is playing dumb for some reason.
However, it is meant to be resolved by doing this.
Was? GPG?
Müsste das nicht PGP heißen?
Knu PG löschen?
Okay. Probieren wir mal aus,
ob das funktioniert.
Muss man das alles gut machen? Wahrscheinlich.
Jawoll.
Ach, not to be confused
with pretty good privacy.
Aha. Okay.
Aber ich hab's gerade
confused damit.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt geht's, oder wie?
Yes.
Force Champ?
Nope.
Funktioniert nicht.
Sproken.
Kekkel.
Also das war auf jeden Fall nicht der Flink.
Was das soll ich machen,
was ihr da gepostet habt?
Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Chat, wenn ihr das sagt.
Chat ist high IQ, der weiß sowas.
Ich truste. Ich truste dem Dark Reader.
Ich truste dem Chat, Leute.
Massive Chat Trust.
Funktioniert nicht.
Nee, nee, Manjaro funktioniert gar kein Problem.
Okay, Leute.
Was wie nur Keyring.
Wo hab ich nicht mehr reingeschaut?
Ach so, beim, bei...
Nee, doch.
Manjaro hat funktioniert, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ach so.
Hab ich alles geupgradet?
Yes.
Und jetzt, und jetzt darf ich alles machen.
Aha, aha, aha.
Das funktioniert jetzt.
Easy.
Wieder was gelernt, Chat.
Chat ist richtig high IQ
heute wieder.
Gut, hätten wir das auch geregelt?
Wollte ich jetzt zwar gar nicht machen, aber gut zu wissen.
Welche Version von
Forever Workstation hast du?
Forever Workstation.
Ach so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Lizenz zeigen kann.
Lieber nicht.
Wer weiß.
Ja, aber es ist nicht Player.
Es ist das Normale.
Weiß nicht, warum man sich Player kaufen sollte.
Kriegst du aber auch beim
Keyshop für ein Abel und ein Ei.
Ja, ich glaub, dass ich
Corona hab.
Nee.
Also, noch.
Teile, die an der Mitte der Nase laufen, nicht so viel.
Welche Text-to-Speech-Engine ich verwende?
Ehm.
Gar keine.
Ich verwende
einen, du meinst für solche Sachen
wie das hier, ne?
Oder, oder auch...
Das ist ein koreanischer
Text-to-Speech-Service,
wo ich mir irgendwann mal ein
API-Key generiert hab
und über die API
ich denen was sagen lasse und dann als
runterlade ja der kann zum der kann auch noch mehr also man kann ihn als text to
speech ein bisschen zweckentfremden ich kann jetzt zum beispiel hier was
reinschreiben zum beispiel kecke
und jetzt sollte er eigentlich was vorlesen ach so was das funktioniert nicht so wirklich
ok das funktioniert so schon mal nicht anscheinend
ja also man kann ihn auch was anderes sagen lassen
das ist sogar richtig gut
das finde ich gut das muss ich hinzufügen
entdeckt man immer neue sachen was ist denn das längste deutsche wort
du kannst im deutschen theoretisch nahezu beliebig lange wörter geben
ja entdeckt man immer neue sachen was ist denn das längste deutsche wort
generieren ja du kannst hier und du kannst so viele kannst du kannst total
viele wörter im deutsch machen noch länger sind weil wir start shirt ok
logisch ob also das hat sich tatsächlich an als wäre es er ging etwas koreanische
mehr
Koreanisch.
Koreanisch war das, glaube ich, sogar.
Oder war das...
Nee, ich glaube, es war sogar ein koreanischer.
Wie blendest du die Grafiken?
Einer hier mit.
Mit dem Tool.
Nur vom anderen Bildschirm aus.
Das ist netzwerkfähig, das Ding.
Kannst du aufmachen vom anderen Rechner und kannst du...
Ich habe genau den gleichen Kram auf der anderen Seite.
Den kann ich auf dem anderen Bildschirm anklicken.
Ich kann sogar auf dem anderen Bildschirm Moven anmachen.
Beides.
Ich mache es mit der Maus, aber ich habe auch Ctrl-L.
Ich habe auch Keybindings.
Man muss echt sagen, die Software ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber die ist nie richtig fertig geworden.
Sie funktioniert gut genug für mich.
Geil.
Ja.
Der Etiketten-Champ muss auch mal fertig werden.
Der Label-Champ.
Nee.
Ich habe das absichtlich nicht mit dem Stream-Deck gemacht.
Weil ich will es über den Browser bedienen vom zweiten Rechner.
Und ich will ja die Bilder selbst sehen.
Bei mir ist es ja so, das ist nicht irgendeine OBS-Geschichte.
Sondern wirklich, ich sehe die Bilder selbst.
Danke, Patrick.
Noch ist es ja nicht raus, ob es wirklich Corona ist.
Ich hoffe ja nicht.
Ja, ihr müsst euch jetzt auch alle testen lassen.
Kommt drauf an, für was.
Pauschal kann man das überhaupt nicht sagen.
Oh je.
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen.
Java Applets, ist klar.
Habe ich MonkaW überhaupt aktiviert, Leute?
MonkaW habe ich glaube ich gar nicht.
Hauptsache, wir haben MonkaW als Text-to-Speech.
Weil ich habe MonkaW nicht aktiviert.
Weil wir haben schon total viele Monka-Emotes.
Und.
Ich mag MonkaW eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich habe das jetzt bloß reingemacht, weil es sich irgendwie lustig anhört.
Was mir gerade einfällt.
Ich habe mal auf der Arbeit einen aus Versehen voll verwirrt.
Der ist zu mir an den Rechner gekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich darauf komme, Leute.
Jetzt.
Der ist zu mir an den Rechner gekommen, hinter einem Platz.
Und meinte irgendwie, lass mal das und das gucken.
Ist auch egal.
Es geht überhaupt nicht darum.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja.
Moment.
Ich muss mal ein paar Sachen zumachen.
Ich hatte irgendwie 1000 Tabs auf.
Dann habe ich meine Tabs zugeklickt.
Und auf einmal hat man ganz kurz.
Bevor jetzt einer was sagt, Chat.
Ihr müsst warten, bis ich fertig erzählt habe.
Und in einem der Tabs hat man ganz kurz erkannt, Porn.
Und ich habe die Tabs ganz schnell zugemacht.
Und da meinte er, Max, Max, was war das?
Was war das? Porn?
Porn? Was ist da?
Und da habe ich dann die Tabs wieder aufgemacht.
Irgendwie 50 Tabs oder so habe ich wieder aufgemacht.
Um ihm zu zeigen, dass es Unix-Porn war.
Ein Subreddit, wo die Leute ihre gestylten Linux-Desktops zeigen.
Und der Kerl hat halt nur.
Ja, Reddit.
Reddit, please.
Highspeed-Reddit.
Sag mal, ist Reddit down?
Scheint jetzt zu gehen.
So.
So, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor.
Es macht jemand ganz schnell.
Ganz schnell.
Die Sachen zu, ne?
Und ihr habt ja bloß kurz gesehen, die Überschrift.
Dann kann das schon ein bisschen verwirren.
Ja, gebe ich zu.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er das so schnell da oben.
Adressleiste erkannt hat.
Sind das hier Weeb-Diskussionen im Chat?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Chat?
In oder out heute?
In oder out?
Die Lammers sind am Start, ja.
Tja.
Okay.
Arch, by the way.
Hat funktioniert.
Update.
Alles klar.
Nice, kann man da.
Dazu kann man bloß sagen.
Easy.
Und.
Ach, Quatsch.
Was mache ich denn?
Jay darf sich selber updaten.
Wunderbar.
Was ist das für ein Arch?
Arch.
Ganz normales, klassisches Arch, by the way.
Mehr Arch geht nicht.
Warum mal rebooten?
Hä?
Na gut.
Oh, PC-Speaker ist an.
By the way.
Arch, by the way.
Muss ich, by the way, mal ausschalten, weil ich brauche es gerade überhaupt nicht.
Alles klar.
So.
Doch.
Das wird aber die neue Stream-VM, wenn wir die irgendwann mal fertig eingerichtet haben.
So lange bleibt die alte noch da.
Ja.
Weil ich original, by the way, Arch haben will.
Macht gar nichts.
Es gibt heute gar keinen Stream.
Nee.
Irgendjemand im Chat hat geschrieben.
Das angeblich Arch-Repo-Updates nicht mehr funktionieren.
Das musst du gerade mal ausprobieren.
Ansonsten habe ich nichts geplant.
Ich muss euch aber doch noch was sagen.
Wisst ihr, was mich auf diesem Konzert übelst genervt hat?
Nee.
Die habe ich schon längst entsorgt.
Ach so.
Nee.
Die, die ich angefangen habe, das ist die hier, die ich die ganze Zeit verwende.
Die ist die Poggers-VM.
Also eine Sache.
Also eine Sache, sage ich gleich was zu dem anderen.
Also eine Sache, die mir wirklich auf den Keks gegangen ist bei dem Konzert, ist.
Also mit dem Sound habe ich mich ja schon drüber aufgeregt.
Ähm.
Nee, über Handys auch nicht.
Über Handys gar nicht so sehr.
Über diese Völkerwanderung, die bei manchen Leuten abging.
Ey.
Ich muss mich teilweise.
Fünfmal in der Minute sind dann Leute an mir vorbeigelaufen.
Die sind permanent.
Rein, raus, hochgelaufen, runtergelaufen, während die Bands gespielt haben.
Wo ich mir so denke, warum seid ihr eigentlich hier?
Also was macht ihr eigentlich hier?
Die sind, die sind hyper agile, ja.
Aber was cool war.
Es war wirklich komplettes.
So Treffen der Generation.
Nee, du musst nicht zum Dixi Klo.
Das ist mitten im Wald.
Ähm.
Deutsche Bank Park.
Früher ist es mal Waldstadion.
Da hast du Klos und alles da.
Und das war halt wirklich cool.
Das war wirklich Treffen, Treffen der Generation.
Du hattest da welche, keine Ahnung.
Die waren zwölf Eltern da.
Großeltern da.
Also von zwölf bis an die 80 war da alles da.
Die meisten waren so in meinem Alter, würde ich sagen.
Ja, mir sind das normalerweise auch zu viele Menschen.
Aber ab und zu geht das mal.
Das nächste Mal ist dann wieder.
Äh.
November, ich glaube, am 25.
November in der Jahrhunderthalle.
Geht zwar jetztlichen Power Metal.
Die sind aber wirklich nice.
Und was ich leider, wo ich leider verpasst habe, ist Moment.
Warte, ich dachte, ich dachte, das war schon okay.
Als bin ich auch am Start.
Äh, was war das für ein Desktop?
Environment?
Das war doch nicht die drei.
Doch, das ist die drei.
Das hier ist die drei.
Und das andere, was du gesehen hast hier, war auch die drei.
Alles die drei.
Also warum ich Windows verwende und warum nicht Linux?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob du mein letztes Video gesehen hast.
Da geht es ja um dieses, um dieses Thema unter anderem.
Und ich brauche halt einige Sachen, die man am besten unter Windows macht.
Und ich mache aber auch viele Sachen lieber unter Linux.
So, und nachdem ich die Sachen, die ich unter Windows mache, besser unter einem Native Windows machen kann.
Nämlich zum Beispiel Spiele spielen.
Alles unter einem virtualisierten Windows.
Habe ich so rum.
VM ist für mich performance-technisch top.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber performance-technisch Spiele in der VM wäre nicht gut.
Und jetzt kommt mir keiner mit GPU-Pass.
Dann hast du wieder ganz andere Probleme.
Kann man alles machen.
Schön in der Benutzung ist es nicht.
So, und ich mache es halt so.
Ich mache Streaming, Spiele, Video-Editieren und das Zeug mache ich unter Windows.
Den Rest mache ich unter Linux in der VM.
Das ist für mich die beste Kombination.
Vor allem ist es kein Dual-Boot, weil Dual-Boot würde mich nerven zwischendurch.
Ich will beide Systeme gleichzeitig haben.
Die haben wenig gefilmt.
Die waren einfach nur da und sind die ganze Zeit rein und raus gelaufen.
Und das ist das, was ich mache.
Was ist das Besondere an i3?
Dass du keine Fenster hast.
Guck mal, hier habe ich einen Browser auf.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Terminal aufmache, nimmt es die Hälfte des Platzes.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch einen Terminal aufmache, nimmt es ein Drittel des Platzes.
Ich kann es natürlich auch umschieben.
Aber das soweit alles mit Tastatur.
Und du musst dich nicht mehr um Fenstermanagement kümmern.
Es war am Anfang, ich gebe das zu, das war am Anfang schon gewöhnungsbequem.
Es war am Anfang schon gewöhnungsbequem.
Ich durfte sich an i3 zu gewöhnen.
Vor allem mit mehreren Desktops und sowas.
Normalerweise habe ich es ja so.
Ich habe hier irgendeine IDE auf.
Hier habe ich einen Terminal, hier habe ich einen Browser.
Ich habe nur noch Fullscreen.
Man kann, wenn man will,
Wenn man will, kann man Fenstermodus machen.
Was habe ich da für China-Chinesen-Dinge im Hintergrund?
Wallpaper.
Jawohl.
Beste.
Ja.
Du kannst Fenster machen und Fenster hin und her schieben.
Aber, also kannst du machen, ist aber reichlich sinnlos.
Macht man eigentlich kaum besser.
Alles den Window-Manager teilen lassen.
So und du hast noch ein paar mehr Funktionen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel, was ich halt auch wirklich praktisch finde.
Du kannst zum Beispiel, stell dir mal vor, du hast hier oben irgendwas Wichtiges laufen.
Ja.
Du hast hier oben irgendwie deinen aktuellen Stonk-Sticker,
den man nur verkaufen muss oder was weiß ich.
Also du hast hier oben irgendwas Wichtiges laufen.
Dann kannst du so Sachen machen, wie du drückst Windows-Taste S.
Und dann hast du über alle Desktops, selbst wenn du die Desktops durchswitchst,
hast du das Sticky.
Dieses eine Fenster da oben.
Also man kann schon coole Sachen machen mit i3.
Ja oder zum Beispiel, stellt euch mal vor, ihr guckt einen Stream.
Ihr guckt Wobblors Twitch.
Gucken, ob das jetzt auch funktioniert.
Ihr guckt Wobblors.
Oder was anderes, der Chat.
Chat ist ein besseres Beispiel.
Guckt mal.
Also ihr habt den Chat auf.
Ja.
Und dann könntet ihr theoretisch den Chat irgendwo da oben hinschieben.
Und dann Sticky machen.
Auf jedem Desktop hätte man dann den Chat.
Also man kann damit schon coole Sachen machen.
Du du du du du du.
Du kannst auch einen Tab-Layout machen oder einen Stack-Layout.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich brauche Browser-Terminal-Editor.
Ja manchmal zwei, drei Editor-Fenster.
Fertig.
Ja man kann, wie gesagt, das coole unter i3 ist halt,
dass man Floating-Windows machen kann.
Aber zum größten Teil, man sich damit gar nicht beschäftigen muss.
Ja und was jetzt der bessere Tiling-Window-Manager ist,
da gibt es ja immer große Diskussionen.
Manche sagen gar nicht mehr X, sondern direkt Wayland und Sway.
Andere sagen Awesome-WM.
Andere sagen Herbst-Luft-WM, was es wirklich gibt.
Das hat wirklich einen ziemlich beknackten Namen, aber okay.
Manche sagen DWM.
Manche sagen BSP-WM.
Du fandest dieses Tutorial gut.
Ja.
Das ist zwar von 2015, aber von den Basics.
Aber von den Basics her passt das ohne Probleme noch.
Da hat sich nicht so viel dran getan.
Ich meine, das ist sehr minimalistisch.
Was soll sich am Windows-Teilen ändern in sieben Jahren?
ASCII-Quarium ist selbstverständlich wichtig.
Windows-Taste Linux, das geht, ja.
Ja, ja, das funktioniert, ja.
Oh man sieht, man sieht, es escapete gar nicht.
Okay.
Ja, also es funktioniert.
Guckt, also du kannst, ich mache Windows-Taste 1, 2, 3,
um die Desktops durchzuswitchen.
Reicht deine Grafikkarte für alles noch?
Naja, ja, aber ich würde jetzt schon eine neuere kaufen.
Und ich würde, also, weil irgendjemand meinen PC gerade angezeigt hat, ja.
Den PC würde ich heute so nicht kaufen mehr, ne.
Falls irgendeiner auf die glorreiche Idee kommt und sagt,
ich will den PC kaufen, wie der Max den hat.
Nee, nee, das würde ich auf gar keinen Fall mehr so machen.
Ich meine, das ist schon ziemlich outdated.
Das ist ein PC von 2017.
Aber immer noch ziemlich gut.
Das ist, wisst ihr, das ist ja so das, was mich total fertig macht.
Dass ich irgendwie den fünf Jahre alten PC verwenden kann,
so wie ein High-End-Gerät und alles spielen kann.
Also so wie ein High-End-Gerät von damals 2005 oder so.
Das ist Wahnsinn, also da tut sich nicht mehr so viel.
Red, stimmt, das gab es auch noch.
Ja gut, das ist ja nicht exklusiv.
Ich verwende das ja auch.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich verwende ja auch T-Max im Terminal und einen Tiling-Window-Manager drumherum.
Ja, für die Splits in dem Fall bräuchte ich es nicht unbedingt.
Aber gerade, dass du Kommandos im Hintergrund laufen lassen kannst,
dass du den Copy-Buffer ordentlich durchsuchen kannst und so.
Äh, nicht den Copy-Buffer, den Scrollback-Buffer ordentlich durchsuchen kannst.
Ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Das Fenster über mehrere Desktops floaten.
Geht das wirklich nicht?
Sekunde.
Ne, das geht tatsächlich nicht.
Warum ist in Windows alles so halbherzig kacke gemacht?
Das Fenster ist nicht auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Das ging unter Linux damals mit, als Ubuntu noch mit Compets gerne benutzt wurde.
Das ging 2008 ohne Probleme.
Wieso sollte es denn da sein?
Naja, wenn man der Logik folgt und sagt,
mehrere Desktops sind quasi,
tja, wie die Seiten von einem Würfel nebeneinander,
dann müsste der Kram das Fenster hier so um die Ecke rappen.
Und halt dann auf dem Desktop halbe-halbe sein.
Ich mein, es geht auf Desktop 1 raus,
und dann würde man eigentlich erwarten, dass es links auf Desktop 2 wieder reinkommt.
Wobei man das unter Compets auch unterschiedlich einstellen konnte.
Ich glaube, man konnte das unter Compets auch so machen.
Dass es nicht der Fall war.
Ja, hab ich.
Ich hab damals irgendwie ne WIM-Config mit 5000 Zeilen oder so gehabt.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich hatte Fuzzy Finder Plugins, Autocomplete Plugins,
wahrscheinlich alles Sachen, die man heute gar nicht verwendet,
sondern es neuere Versionen davon gibt, alles möglich.
Ja, ich hab WIM wirklich aufgebohrt bis zum Gehtnichtmehr.
Fand ich aber im Nachhinein betrachtet nicht sonderlich schlau.
Und ich bin froh, dass ich das nicht mehr mache, weil,
man gewöhnt sich dran, dass WIM so komisch konfiguriert ist.
Und dann erwartest du auf dem Server, dass es auch so ist.
Man vergisst die Basic Editier-Sachen,
wenn man solche Sachen hat wie Sneak, wo man in einer Zeile rumspringen kann.
Und man hat's auf dem Server halt nicht.
Wo man eigentlich WIM braucht zum Editieren.
Und ganz im Ernst, so toll das ist, Sachen auf der Kommandozeile zu machen,
man muss aber gucken, halt Sachen dort machen, wo es irgendwie sinnvoll ist.
Ich muss sagen, als Texteditor WIM auf dem Terminal für kleine Editieraufgaben
und auf dem Server, um Remote was zu editieren, wunderbar.
Aber ich möchte beispielsweise keinen Terminal-Editor mehr verwenden,
als hauptsächliches Tool.
Allein schon so Sachen wie Minimaps, Parameter-Highlights und sowas,
das ist ein Krampf im WIM.
Ja, die 1080 TI ist ziemlich gut.
Jaja, die 1080 TI war richtig gut.
Danke nochmal an Nvidia.
Das war, glaube ich, eines der nachhaltigsten Sponsorings, die ich je gemacht habe.
Die 1080 TI.
POG, echt POG-Karte.
Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Ja, das war ein Fehler.
Ja gut, SSD habe ich mittlerweile.
Ich habe immer noch die SSD drin, aber noch was Größeres.
CPU ist die gleiche.
RAM ist mittlerweile mehr drin.
Guck, RAM habe ich mittlerweile 32G.
Aber ansonsten ist es exakt der gleiche Rechner noch.
Nur ein bisschen mehr RAM und ein bisschen mehr SSD.
Weird Flex, welcher Flex war weird?
RAM.
RAM ist nicht Weird Flex, RAM ist das Beste.
Man kann nie genug RAM haben.
Was ich mir für einen PC heute holen würde,
das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen,
weil ich immer nur auf dem aktuellen Stand bin,
was Desktop-Hardware angeht.
Wenn ich mir einen kaufe
und vor einem Jahr
oder wann kam die aktuelle Ryzen raus?
Vor eineinhalb, zwei Jahren?
Also, als die neue Ryzen-Generation angekündigt wurde,
da wollte ich einen 5900X kaufen.
Aber nachdem sich das dann alles nicht gekauft hat,
erst mal hast du nichts bekommen.
Dann hast du was bekommen.
Aber Grafikkarten waren unendlich teuer und so was.
Da habe ich meinen Rechner einfach immer weiter verwendet.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt einen neuen kaufen müsste,
müsste ich selbst erst mal nachgucken,
was sich aktuell anbietet.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass es wieder ein Intel-System wird.
Kann aber auch sein, dass es ein AMD-System wird.
Das könnte ich so gar nicht sagen.
Mal gucken, wann habe ich denn den...
Ja, Oktober 2017.
Alter, fünf Jahre alt ist der Rechner.
Kackel, Mann.
Ich warte auch ab.
Ich kann ja aktuell alles spielen, was ich spielen will.
Ach ja, es war die Frage, was ich aktuell spiele.
Also, ich habe Stray gespielt,
aber noch nicht ganz durch.
Ich spiele gerade wieder ein bisschen Crim Dawn,
weil ich sonst nichts Besseres zu tun habe als spielen.
Und dann vielleicht mal wieder die neue PoE-Liga,
die irgendwie nächsten Monat rauskommt.
Im August.
Ansonsten habe ich letztens in Strategie...
Ihr werdet lachen.
Ein Anime-Strategie-Game durchgespielt.
Ihr habt richtig gehört bei mir auf dem Stream, ja.
Ich habe tatsächlich...
Ja, wobei.
So richtig...
Eher sowas wie Fire Emblem war das.
Nur nicht Fire Emblem.
Sowas...
halt auf dem PC.
Fire Emblem ist ja nicht wirklich so krasses Weep-Game,
oder nein, irgendwo schon.
Aber sowas in der Richtung wie Fire Emblem war das.
Habe ich letztens gespielt.
Ähm...
Und ansonsten gibt es aktuell leider nicht so viel,
was mich an Games so richtig abholt, ja.
Anime-Strategie gibt es, na klar.
Guck dir Fire Emblem an.
Das Game, warte mal, wie hieß das denn?
Ähm...
Steam Symphony of War oder sowas?
Das da?
Ja, genau.
Das da.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Fire Emblem, ja.
Also so mit Maps und Einheiten rum und so.
War eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich meine, hat...
Overwhelming positive.
Ach ja.
Und für alle Anime-Fans,
der...
Wie nennt man das?
Der Waifu-Alarm war sehr hoch.
Da war für jeden was dabei.
Ja.
Aber Gameplay-technisch fand ich es wirklich nicht schlecht.
Ich meine,
war overwhelming positive bei...
Bei 2500 Bewertungen nicht verkehrt.
Das habe ich letztens gespielt.
Ja, und ansonsten gibt es leider nicht so viel,
was mich so catcht an Games gerade.
Leider.
Wisst ihr, ich hätte richtig Bock drauf,
mal wieder nen MMO...
zu spielen.
Am besten, wenn es halt neu rauskommt.
Und kein Asia-Pay-to-Win-Shit-MMO,
sondern irgendein gutes MMO.
Das Problem ist halt,
es gibt kaum noch gute MMOs.
Beziehungsweise es kommen ja eigentlich keine MMOs mehr raus.
Und wenn sie rauskommen,
sind das irgendwelche Asia-Pay-to-Win-Dinger.
Wisst ihr, damals dachte ich,
als zu Zeiten von Dark Age of Camelot
und später World of Warcraft und sowas,
da dachte ich mir,
Mann, wie geil müssen MMOs erst sein 2020.
Tja.
Hast du falsch gedacht.
Die besten MMOs kamen damals raus.
Das neue Riot-MMO.
Ja.
Vielleicht.
Also ich würde gern wieder nen MMO spielen,
wo ich von Anfang an dabei bin.
Und was mir irgendwie auch direkt zusagt.
Ja.
Es gibt so Spiele,
da seh ich schon die ersten Screenshots
und denk mir so,
hm, na.
Nicht.
Ja.
Genauso, wenn sie anfangen,
immer dann gleich mit Survival-Elementen
in nem MMO und sowas.
Ich mein nur,
weil die ganzen Zombie-Survival-Dinger
so extrem angesagt waren,
heißt das nicht,
dass man MMOs mit Survival-Elementen machen muss,
oder?
Ich bin auch überhaupt kein Freund von
Permadeath-Systemen.
Hast in MMOs weniger,
aber es gibt ziemlich viele Spiele
die letzten Jahre,
die das halt mit Survival kombinieren.
Und ich mag Permadeath halt
in keinem Game.
Das einzige Game, wo Permadeath
halbwegs,
ähm,
halbwegs gut war,
war Darkest Dungeon.
Moment,
da gibt's nen zweiten Teil von?
was?
Davon gibt's nen zweiten Teil?
Seit wann denn das?
Kackel.
Also,
da war Permadeath okay.
Wobei es halt nicht Permadeath
im eigentlichen Sinne war.
Also,
du bist ja nicht gestorben.
Es konnten halt deine Helden,
konnten sterben.
Und wenn nicht sterben,
dann halt zumindest
die Helden.
Also,
wenn ich sterbe,
dann halt zumindest
die Helden.
Also,
wenn ich sterbe,
dann halt zumindest
die Helden.
Also,
wenn ich sterbe,
dann halt zumindest
irgendwelche,
ähm,
Permanente Debuffs
davontragen und so.
Das war das einzige Game,
was mir Bock gemacht hat
mit sowas wie
Permadeath.
Ach,
das ist ein Epic Store
Exclusive,
verstehe.
Deswegen hab ich das nicht
mitgekriegt.
Ja,
Mausbeschleunigung ist ja auch
wirklich
menschenverachtend,
ja.
Was spielt ihr denn aktuell
so,
Chat,
wo wir grad beim Thema sind?
Äh,
ja,
ähm,
die Elden Ring
hab ich mir zur Release gekauft.
Ich hab's bis jetzt
noch nicht gespielt.
Wobei ich's mir fest
vorgenommen hab,
das wirklich
der Sache mal
eine Chance zu geben.
Ich bin kein riesiger
Dark Souls Fan,
aber
Elden Ring soll ja auch
für Leute
erträglich sein,
die Dark Souls
jetzt nicht so geil fanden.
Cringe,
wer unter 3 Terabyte
rammert,
ja,
Hyper Cringe.
Was ist jetzt los?
Ach so,
das ist ja 5 Minuten her,
ich bin im Chat
einfach zu langsam.
Übrigens noch mal
eine
eine,
eine Frage,
wo ihr raten könnt,
Leute,
im Chat.
Was meint ihr,
was im,
also beim
Iron Maiden Konzert
in Frankfurt
in der,
im Deutsche Bank Park,
also im Stadion drinne,
was meint ihr,
was die Portion
Pommes Frites gekostet hat?
So eine Tüte Pommes.
Ratet mal.
Was hat
eine Tüte
Pommes gekostet?
6,50,
6,20 Euro.
Ihr seid,
ihr seid
alle falsch,
Chat.
Alle falsch,
alle falsch.
Ah,
wir kommen in die,
okay,
ich sag's euch,
9 Euro.
Tüte Pommes Frites.
Das Brötchen
mit einer Wurst drauf.
Also Brötchen,
das war ein popeliges Brötchen,
ja.
Brötchen,
Wurst
und ein bisschen Senf drauf
hat 5 Euro gekostet.
Und
0,5,
0,5
trinken
im Iron Maiden
Becher
hat,
glaube ich,
4,80 gekostet
oder so.
Und
0,5
gekostet
oder so.
Wobei das
einmalig
okay war,
weil den Becher
hab ich mit heimgenommen.
Ja,
das ist,
das ist okay gewesen.
Aber 9 Euro
für die Pommes,
Alter,
null.
Also hab ich nicht gekauft.
Siehst
ja beim
Vorbeilaufen.
Du konntest
ja auch
ein Crepes holen
für 4,50
oder so.
Also es war,
also es war wirklich
teuer.
Genau,
ich hab's zweimal gekauft.
Twitch,
die regelt.
Und jetzt bin ich pleite.
Jetzt brauch ich
eure ganzen Prime Subs.
Sonst
kann ich mir morgen
nix zu essen
kaufen.
Okay.
Hell and Loose.
Ja, ich wollte schon lange
mal ausprobieren,
aber ich glaube,
da kommt man nicht mehr
richtig rein jetzt.
Was nutze
Linux portiert
auf dem USB,
weil eine VM
die Performance
auseinander nimmt.
Was?
Der Satz
ergibt für mich
jetzt wenig Sinn.
Hä?
Du willst
ein persistentes System
haben,
was du
annehmen kannst
oder wie?
Jailor war
das Möb
war der erste,
der halbwegs richtig
liegt.
Lag.
Was ist denn Web
Application 11
in der Taskleiste?
Das hier ist das.
Das ist die Anwendung,
mit der ich Bilder
overlayen kann
oder oder
zum Beispiel
oder zum Beispiel
sagen lassen
kann
oder um die Leute
zu verwirren.
Ich kann damit
beispielsweise
auch
solche
solche,
wie
das
machen
oder das,
was jeder mag.
Das ist Web
Application 11
Windows
zu
Go auf einem
USB mit
vor
einmal
Hotels
Lauf
Way to
Smart
Pfeifen
genau
selbst
entwickelte
Battlefield 2042
Hex
Tja,
sollte ich
vielleicht mal
ausprobieren.
Ja,
kann ich mir
ja
haben.
Den habe ich gebannt,
den Halt
Rated Bot.
Da ging mir auf den Keks.
Der ist,
der ist geblockt.
Der kann ihn nicht mehr
reiten.
Ja,
ja,
schon ewig.
Den habe ich bestimmt
schon drei Jahre
gebannt oder so.
Kauf dir jetzt
keinen neuen PC.
Solange
deiner noch
läuft.
Es ist immer
das Beste
abzuwarten.
Außer du hast
jetzt einen
konkreten Anwendungsfall,
wo du sagst,
dafür reicht es nicht
mehr.
Mache ich auch.
Mache ich.
Ich warte auf die 4900.
Ich warte auf neue
CPU Generation
und 4900.
Und dann hole ich
mir vielleicht
einen neuen PC.
Die Intel Karten,
das wird eh wieder
so
Reinfall.
Leute,
ich glaube, ich muss echt
mal Fieber messen.
Ich sage es euch.
Also ich habe mir
gerade so im Kopf.
Es fühlt sich schon
warm an.
Also wärmer,
wärmer als sonst
auf jeden Fall.
Ja,
na ja.
Also ich hoffe nicht.
Also ich hoffe
immer noch nicht,
dass es Corona ist.
Und selbst
wenn es Corona ist.
Ich meine,
ich bin.
Wie oft geimpft
bin ich?
Was ist normal?
Dreifach ist,
wenn man alles
gemacht hat,
was es,
was,
was es so gab,
oder?
Und ich guck mal kurz
in meine Corona App.
Das steht doch da irgendwie.
Ja,
ich habe das
immer noch drauf.
Ich würde es jetzt
nicht mal neu installieren,
aber.
Ja,
ich glaube,
ich habe Bluetooth aus.
Deswegen funktioniert
das nicht.
Nee,
ich habe noch keinen
Schnelltest gemacht
und ich glaube,
es ist einfach
auch noch zu früh
für den Schnelltest.
Weil das Konzert
war am Dienstag.
Das ist ja gerade mal
zwei Tage her,
wenn du es so willst.
Und die Schnelltests
so richtig
hinhauen
tun die ja
frühestens
eigentlich
nach vier Tagen
bestimmt
gleich.
Was ist da eigentlich
passiert?
Was ist da
Was ist da eigentlich
raus geworden?
Lange nichts mehr
gehört.
Tja,
ich würde mich nicht
darauf verlassen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich denke
auch normaler.
Ich habe ja heute
morgen im Internet
geguckt.
Ja,
normale Inkubationszeit
bei Corona
sind irgendwie
zwischen vier und
sechs Tagen.
Aber ich meine,
okay,
wir hatten jetzt auch
jemand vorhin im Chat,
der gesagt hat,
bei ihm war es genauso.
Es ist ja noch nicht
krass.
Mir tut ein bisschen
der Hals weh
durch.
Also ich glaube,
Leute, die da nicht so
genau drauf achten,
die würden wahrscheinlich
noch sagen,
das ist doch alles
normal.
Ja,
das ist wahrscheinlich
normal,
dass es so anfängt.
Ja,
ich,
ich wollte morgen
tatsächlich ins Büro
fahren,
aber ich glaube,
das lasse ich,
das lasse ich.
Also
das ist ein Link.
Ich weiß nicht,
was sich dahinter
verbirgt,
aber
das,
das mache ich nicht
auf bei diesem Titel.
Also
ich hoffe,
es ist nicht so wild.
Also
würde gerne deine Meinung
zu folgender Situation
wissen.
Angenommen,
du bist Fullstack
Webentwickler mit TypeScript.
Okay.
Und hast du ein Jobangebot
als Cloud Architekt
Azure mit C Sharp
als Backend
oder Fullstack?
Also das erste,
was ich mich fragen würde,
ist.
Also
kannst du das?
Also ich meine,
ich würde jetzt
davon ausgehen.
Ja,
du kannst das,
weil ansonsten
hätten sie dir
kein Angebot gemacht.
Es ist ja schon
ein bisschen was anderes.
Also hast du Ahnung
von Cloud Architektur
und von Azure.
Ansonsten
ist es halt
ziemlich ins kalte
Wasser gesprungen.
Ja,
man kann das sicherlich
alles lernen.
Aber wenn du irgendwo
anfängst,
wo aus
Gründen
der Job Bezeichnung
von dir erwartet
wird,
dass du das kannst
und du kannst
es dann nicht,
ist vielleicht
auch nicht so
die beste Voraussetzung.
Was ist denn
ein Web 3
Entwurf?
Also
was ist denn
ein Web 3
Entwickler?
Willst du irgendwelche
NFT Geschichten
machen oder
dezentrales
Blockchain
Pfeiffer Zeug?
Ansonsten
ganz ehrlich
kann ich dir
es nicht beantworten.
Nee,
wir sind bei
Web 3
ist doch das Blockchain
Zeug.
Ich kann es.
Ich kann es
hier nicht wirklich
beantworten.
Also ich
ich persönlich
würde auf
jeden Fall
das hier machen
anstatt das andere.
Aber das kann
ich so nicht wissen
bei dir.
Keine Ahnung.
Du musst nicht
zwangsläubig was mit Terraform
machen, aber
es ist auf jeden Fall
nicht verkehrt von
genau solchen Sachen
Ahnung zu haben,
bevor man
Cloud Architekt
wird.
Bisschen komische
Kombination
Cloud Architekt
mit C Sharp
als also
du bastelst
da nicht am Backend
rum oder
oder bist du quasi
quasi
volles Stack
Entwickler
dann Frontend
Backend
und Cloud
Infrastruktur
Complete Stack.
Ja, also meine Gedanken
sind ich persönlich
würde das hier
deutlich lieber machen
als das hier.
Erstens, weil ich mir
bei der ganzen Web
drei Geschichte
mich fragen würde,
welcher Laden ist das?
Wo bin ich da gelandet?
Und weil ich
keinen Bock hätte
auf JavaScript
Frontend
den ganzen Tag.
Ich bin ja
aber zumindest
mit Cloud Architektur
schon ein bisschen
auskenne und
C Sharp jetzt auch
nicht das schlechteste
ist bei mir.
Also ich würde
das hier
also für mich
persönlich.
Nicht nichts.
Ja, für mich persönlich
wäre das hier
das die bessere Variante.
Aber vielleicht ist es
bei dir umgedreht.
Vielleicht sagst du
Ja, hiervon habe ich Ahnung.
Davon eigentlich eher nicht.
Dann ist bei dir genau umgedreht.
Gigastack.
Ja, du kannst mal
in der Berufsschule gucken,
ob sie den Lehrplan
irgendwo haben.
Oder den Ausbildungsplan
oder wie das genau heißt.
Und du kannst dich schlau machen,
mit was sich deine Firma,
wo du
also der Betrieb,
wo du die Ausbildung machst,
mit was sie sich sonst
so beschäftigen,
was sie so machen
und dann gucken,
ob man sich da irgendwie
darauf vorbereiten kann.
Aber ansonsten muss man
auch ganz klar sagen,
Ausbildung ist ja dafür da,
dass man was lernt,
nicht, dass man schon alles kann.
Seltsam.
Welche Sprache
für Anfänger?
JavaScript.
Allein schon
aus zwei Gründen.
Der Einstieg ist
einfach nix hier.
Das ist
einfach
nix.
Das ist
einfach
nix.
Das ist
einfach nix.
Java zum Einstieg.
JavaScript.
Der Einstieg ist
mit Abstand
am einfachsten.
Du brauchst nur
einen Editor
und einen Browser.
Und
das zweite ist
an Frontend-Technologien,
also in dem Fall
JavaScript,
HTML,
CSS,
kommt niemand vorbei.
Und sei es
nur ein bisschen.
Und dann
wird das abgeschrieben
und ein paar Fax
verschickt
oder wie.
Programmieren
WDR Maus.
Rede mit was?
Was?
Programmieren
mit der Maus.
Blockly
Hey, das ist
eine richtig gute Idee,
Leute.
Warum ist das
alles so
ausgegraut?
Das ist
eine richtig,
das ist eine richtig gute
Idee.
Warum kann man
das hier nicht
anklicken?
Blöde Frage.
Warum ist das alles
ausgegraut?
Ach, wegen meinem
Dark Mode?
Nö.
Aber das finde ich
ist eine gute Idee,
sowas zu machen.
Aber wenn ich
das.
Ach so.
Hier kann ich
jetzt.
Ne ist eine gute
ist eine gute Idee.
Pogge.
Nice Idee.
Finde ich
gut.
Ja, Battlefield Portal
ist ja auch auf Blockly
Basis.
Sieht man ja auch im
Browser, wenn man sich
die.
Die
Urls anguckt,
was da so nachgeladen
wird und so.
Ganz im Ernst.
Mir ist es lieber.
Die geben Geld
von meinen Gebühren
für sowas.
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Guck mal.
Mir ist es lieber.
Die geben Geld
für sowas aus mit
meinen Gebühren.
Als für Rosamunde Pilcher
oder dicke Backen Musik
oder irgendwie.
Oder oder Florian Silbereisen
der Musikanten Dampfer
und was es da nicht alles
gibt.
Also dann ist mir
dann ist das ist mir.
Doch deutlich lieber.
Eine coole Idee.
Das sind zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Also.
Als wenn du,
wenn du
Du wirst aber dadurch wahrscheinlich in der Berufsschule nicht viel Neues lernen in der Ausbildung.
Was du in der Ausbildung lernst, ist halt, was im Businessumfeld so abgeht.
Ne, ich glaube, dann ist es was anderes.
Aber ob du studieren willst oder eine Ausbildung machen willst, das kann ich dir jetzt ja schlecht beantworten.
Also, wenn du studieren gehen willst, dann geh gleich studieren.
Also, erst das machen, dann das machen, dann studieren gehen ist unsinnig.
Also, die Physi-Ausbildung bringt dir jetzt für das Studium nicht wahnsinnig viel.
Umgedreht würde ich sagen, wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wirklich, weil in der Ausbildung geht es halt eher um die Praxis.
Und im Studium kannst du halt den Binary Tree inverten.
Also, das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen.
Du musst dir aber im Klaren sein, dass ein Informatikstudium jetzt nicht easy as fuck ist.
Also, nicht so nach dem Motto, ah ja, ich setze mich jetzt mal ein paar Stunden in die Uni und dann mache ich easy Mathe.
Und Informatik, ne, ne, so einfach ist das nicht.
Wohingegen die Physi-Ausbildung, was Berufsschule angeht, als schlechter Witz ist.
Also, das schafft jeder.
Selbst ohne aufpassen.
Also, die Physi-Ausbildung ist, was Schule angeht und Lernen angeht, definitiv entspannter.
Also, am Theorieanteil definitiv entspannter, als zu studieren.
Denkst du, dass man bessere Karrierechancen hat mit Studium?
Ja, prinzipiell.
Prinzipiell würde ich sagen, schon.
Ich denke mal, wenn wir uns irgendwelche Gehaltstabellen angucken würden, dann ist es bestimmt auch so, dass im Durchschnitt, wie gesagt, nur im Durchschnitt, das heißt nicht, dass es unbedingt jetzt für dich gelten muss, aber im Durchschnitt, wahrscheinlich Leute, die studiert haben, auch einen Ticken mehr verdienen.
Unterm Strich hängt es am Ende halt aber trotzdem davon ab, was du kannst.
Wir haben beispielsweise bei uns im Support einige Leute sitzen, die haben Informatik studiert.
Zwar kein Mathematiker.
Master.
Sondern nur das davor.
Aber die machen jetzt Support und haben eigentlich voller Technik, naja, nicht so viel mit zu tun und teilweise auch nicht so wirklich viel Ahnung.
Wie, du kannst kein Binary Tree inverten nach dem Informatikstudium?
Dann würde ich sagen, dann haben die aber gefällt.
Doch, hat's.
Informatikstudium hat was mit Mathe und Programmieren zu tun.
Also, jemand, der was anderes, also, ich meine, Leute, ich habe nicht studiert, ja, aber ein bisschen schlau gemacht und auch mit Leuten drüber gesprochen.
Die, die studiert haben, habe ich selbstverständlich ein Informatikstudium, was mit Programmieren und Mathe zu tun.
Ich glaube, die meisten, die Wirtschaftsinformatik studieren, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, ja.
Die wollen einfach, dass der Matheanteil einfacher wird.
Ist so meine persönliche Vermutung, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Also, im Durchschnitt, im Durchschnitt ist es bestimmt so.
Im Durchschnitt werden wahrscheinlich Leute, die studiert haben, mehr verdienen als Leute, die eine Ausbildung gemacht haben.
Und ich gehe aber davon aus, dass sich das mit Berufsjahren ein bisschen angleicht und dass man es dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr so genau erkennt.
Weil, wo es einen Riesenunterschied macht, ist wohl wahrscheinlich, wenn du bei irgendwelchen Behörden arbeitest.
Die haben da halt sehr starre Vorgaben.
Ja, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber es hört sich schon ein bisschen so an.
Weil, ich meine, dein Chef weiß doch, was du kannst.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen,
dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast, dass du so viel Geld hast.
Also, das ist jetzt eine gewisse Frage.
Dass du nach deiner Ausbildung neben dem Beruf ein Studium da noch machst, um mehr Geld zu verdienen.
Weil, du lernst in dem Studium höchstwahrscheinlich nichts, was für deine Arbeit jetzt erstmal so relevant ist, unmittelbar.
Und ich so viel besser machen würde, als wenn du Fachinformatik Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt hast.
Ich meine, du hast es in dem Betrieb gelernt, du weißt, was sie machen.
Das ist mehr als jeder der Informatiker.
studiert hat weiß du weißt wie die wie die projekte laufen du weißt auf was
sie basieren du hast du kennst den die die codebase also das informatik
studieren würde in dem fall jetzt rein arbeitstechnisch wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so viel bringen wenn es ein chef erzählt kann es durchaus im grund sein
dass er sagt ja hättest du studiert wirst du mehr verdienen keine ahnung
das kann jetzt kann man schlecht einschätzen ich meine vielleicht ist er
auch letztendlich gar nicht der das entscheidet sondern irgendeine instanz
oben drüber und ihr seid eine behörde und da muss das so sein
der support würde ich auch nicht machen ja so sehe ich denke ich auch genau also
ich würde nicht sagen dass du pauschal sagen kannst welcher der beiden jetzt am
ende mehr verantwortung übernimmt von verantwortung für was personal projekte
irgendwelche verfügbarkeit sls von was ja das natürlich was anderes
da
ist ja auch in anderen hat es ja einen anderen anreiz das zu machen
da wird viel blödsinn gelabert wenn der tag lang ist man ganz davon abgesehen
gibt es wirklich jemand der ernsthaft cto werden möchte also ich sage nicht
dass es keine leute gibt die cto werden möchten aber die meisten techniker haben
doch auf solche hohen positionen gar keinen bock
meine ausnahmen bestätigen die regel also ich habe zum beispiel ich habe
zum beispiel keine praktik Conchit 구 imp quality usw haben ja schon aus ratios
Death Note eher gekommen mehr nachher wo die多garten ins zimmer左右
im bahnhus auswahl in dem ruine im Code lavor managers wirkte bei von messern
side an animation im Enterprise laut dem
so
erklärt
Excel
ein
warum an dieser Stelle dieser Sortieralgorithmus die bessere Wahl ist,
wenn die Daten so und so da reinkommen.
Das ist vielleicht das, was du nach einem Studium machen kannst,
was du aber nicht unbedingt jetzt rein mit dem Wissen aus der Ausbildung machen kannst.
Natürlich, ganz ehrlich, meistens ist es gar nicht notwendig, dass man das selber weiß.
Man gibt das in Google ein und hat dann, okay, ich habe zur Auswahl
Quicksort, Mergesort, Bubblesort, meine Daten haben maximal 20 Elemente im Array,
also nehme ich das. So, fertig.
Aber wenn du es dann wirklich mathematisch auch belegen willst
oder das fundiert beantworten können musst,
dann bringt dir das schon was, wenn du das weißt.
Wie oft es jetzt vorkommt, hängt sicherlich auch von der Stelle ab.
Vielleicht, ja.
Vielleicht, also seit dem Konzert habe ich Halsweh,
ich muss husten und irgendwie fühle ich mich auch,
man's not hot, fühle ich mich auch warm.
Ich muss mir nachher, wie gesagt, nachher Thermometer in Pobbo mal gucken.
Kann mir einer einen Tipp geben, wie man lokale IP-Adressen eine Domain zuweisen kann,
dass diese auch, naja, du gehst in dein DNS auf deinem Router
und trägst dort den Namen ein und fertig.
Also, ich verstehe das Problem.
Ich verstehe das Problem gerade nicht.
Oder ist das eine Domain, die extern und intern verwendet wird?
Also, für den Fall der Fälle gibt es zwei Varianten.
Du machst Split-DNS, also sprich, du hast intern Sachen,
die aufgelöst werden, aber extern nicht.
Kann man machen, ja.
Zum Beispiel überschreibst du halt in deinem Router-DNS
oder in deinem lokalen DNS manche Adressen
mit lokalen IP-Vorschlägen.
IP-V4-Adressen oder IP-V6-Adressen.
Und alles, was du nicht kennst,
vorbaust du weiter an die öffentlichen DNS-Server.
Oder du kannst theoretisch auch in deinem Public-DNS Private IPs eintragen.
Das geht auch.
Und da kommt ja dann auch keiner hin.
Das sind ja Private IPs.
Also, du kannst ohne Probleme keckw.serv...
Also, hier, keine Ahnung.
Lull.keckw.services kann ohne Probleme...
auflösen auf 192.168.0.1.
Auch Public.
Das funktioniert.
Man kommt halt nirgends wo an.
Nutzt du Linux für die Entwicklung?
Ja, mittlerweile ausschließlich.
Wenn es nicht gerade irgendwelche Windows-Sachen sind,
die ich mache.
Aber ansonsten 95% exklusiv nur unter Linux.
Geht das auf der Fritzbox?
Keine Ahnung.
Leute, kann man in der Fritzbox DNS-Geschichten setzen?
Wahrscheinlich.
Kannst du statische DNS-Einträge machen in der Fritzbox?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja, ja, geht wahrscheinlich, ja.
Was ist das?
Kannst du es aufmachen?
15 Sorting-Algorithms in 6 Minutes.
Harte Kost.
Wir gucken uns jetzt gleich noch das TempleOS-Video an.
Iron Maiden...
Zwei und...
Nee.
26 da in...
In Frankfurt, im Stadion.
Was hast du für Nistro?
Welche Tools nutzt du bezogen auf Linux?
Ich benutze Manjaro.
Das ist so ein Arch-Linux-Abkömmling.
Ja, und als Tools eigentlich zum größten Teil die EDEs von JetBrains.
Hauptsächlich Rider für .NET.
Und halt ansonsten alles Mögliche, was es halt unter Linux so gibt.
Was man so braucht.
Also, der Sound war nicht gut.
Die Band und die Show war nice.
Preis-Leistungstechnik war auch okay, außer das Essen und Trinken.
Ja, und ich hab mir irgendwas eingefangen.
Das wichtigste Tool ASCII-Aquarium.
Ja, ja, eindeutig, eindeutig, ja, ja.
Das muss sein.
Leute, mir tut der Hals weh.
Ich geh jetzt auf...
Hat...
Ging länger, als ich das gedacht habe.
Ich hoffe mal, dass es kein Corona ist, aber drauf ankommen lassen will ich es nicht.
Also, ich will nicht unbedingt...
Alle anstecken jetzt.
Äh, die Minimalinstallation war das und alles selbst gemacht.
Das war original, ja, ja.
Das waren die alten Säcke.
Ab zum Arzt.
Das ist jetzt gerade ein bisschen schwierig.
Das hat 90 Euro gekostet.
Und es ging mit zwei Bands davor.
Und Iron Maiden ging es von...
Ja, 17.50 Uhr in dem Dreh bis 22.45 Uhr.
Also, davon waren...
Iron Maiden waren...
Ich sag mal so...
Auch eins...
Also, auch...
Ja, 100 Minuten ungefähr.
Es war aber richtig geil.
Also, Liederauswahl war wirklich okay.
Viel altes Zeug, wo ich die Texte konnte und mitsingen konnte.
Man, die vier, fünf neuen Songs hätte man sich sparen können, weil...
Die kenne ich nicht, aber...
Ich will mich jetzt ja nicht beschweren, dass sie aktuelles Zeug spielen.
Danke für den Sub.
Danke für die ganzen Subs heute auch, by the way.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich hab nämlich überhaupt nicht...
Überhaupt nicht drauf geachtet.
Tribulon hat auch noch gesubbt.
Ja, das war's.
Gut, hab ich ja nicht viel übersehen.
Dankeschön, Leute.
Also, macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns.
What.cs.
Pog Subscription.
Danke.
Bis dann, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
See you.